ENERGY.
AS CNN'S RENE MARSH REPORTS,
MANY COMPANIES ARE SCRAMBLING TO
MINE THESE ESSENTIAL RESOURCES.
>> ON THE SOUTHWEST COAST OF
GREENLAND, SOME OF THE WORLD'S
RICHEST MEN ARE FUNDING A
MASSIVE TREASURE HUN
INVOLVING A CHOPPER AND A
TRANSMITTER IN HOPES O
DISCOVERING TROVE OF CRITICAL
MATERIALS CAPABLE OF POWERING
THE GREEN ENERGY TRANSITION.
A BAND OF BILLIONAIRES FROM JEFF
BEZOS TO MICHAEL BLOOMBERG AND
BILL GATES IS ALL BETTING THAT
BELOW THE SURFACE OF THE HILLS
AND VALLEYS ON GREENLAND'S DISCO
ISLAND AND PENINSULA, THERE'S
ENOUGH NICKEL, COBALT, AND
COPPER TO POWER HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
>> SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
DEPOSIT THAT WILL BE THE FIRST
OR SECOND LARGEST, MOST
SIGNIFICANT NICKEL COBALT
DEPOSIT IN THE WORLD.
>> THEY'RE BACKING CALIFORNIA
START-UP COBALT METALS, A
MINERAL EXPLORATION COMPANY
PARTNERED WITH BLUEJAY MINING TO
FIND RENEWABLES.
BLUEJAY MINING SAYS GREENLAND'S
ICE MELT IS CHANGING THE GAME
FOR SOURCING THESE SOUGHT AFTER
METALS.
>> YOU CAN SEE THAT YOU ARE
DEALING WITH LONGER WINDOWS FROM
SEA ICE.
WE HAVE LONGER PERIODS WHERE WE
ARE ABLE TO TRANSPORT ORE, METAL
FROM GREENLAND TO THE GLOBAL
MARKET.
>> A CAMP OF 30 GEOLOGISTS,
GEOPHYSICISTS, COOKS, PILOTS,
AND MECHANICS ARE ON SITE AND
CNN IS THE FIRST MEDIA OUTLET TO
GET VIDEO OF THE ACTIVITY
HAPPENING THERE.
THEY'RE TAKING SOIL SAMPLES,
FLYING HELICOPTERS WITH
TRANSMITTERS TO MEASURE THE
ELECTROMAGNETIC FIELD OF THE
SUBSURFACE AND MAP THE LAYERS OF
ROCK BELOW.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS
ANALYZING THE DATA TO PINPOINT
EXACTLY WHERE TO DRILL NEXT
SUMMER.
WHILE THE VANISHING ICE OPENS
OPPORTUNITY FOR UNEARTHING AND
TRANSPORTING THESE METALS, IT'S
ALSO FUELING SEA LEVEL RISE AND
EXTREME WEATHER.
A CONCERN FOR SCIENTISTS IN
EASTERN GREENLAND WORKING BELOW
THE SURFACE OF THE ICE SHEET IN
ICE TUNNELS USING HEAVY
MACHINERY TO DRILL AND RETRIEVE
ICE SAMPLES.
ANALYSIS OF THE 60,000-YEAR-OLD
ICE MAY YIELD CLUES ABOUT
GREENLAND'S PAST CLIMATE.
CONCERN IS ALSO HIGH IN
NORTHWEST GREENLAND WHERE CNN
JOINED A TEAM OF NASA SCIENTISTS
MEASURING ICE MELT ON THE ARCTIC
OCEAN.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT MELT IS HAPPENING NOW,
HOW THAT ICE THAT USED TO
SURVIVE SEVERAL YEARS IN A ROW
IS NOW DISAPPEARING.
>> THE DISAPPEARING ICE
HIGHLIGHTS A UNIQUE DICHOTOMY.
GREENLAND IS GROUND ZERO FOR THE
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT IT COULD ALSO BECOME GROUND
ZERO FOR SOURCING THE METALS
NEEDED TO POWER THE SOLUTION TO
THE CRISIS.
AND THE CLIMATE AND TAX BILL
THAT THE SENATE JUST PASSED IF
IT BECOMES LAW WILL ACCELERATE
THE SHIFT TO CLEAN ENERGY AND
GREENLAND'S SIGNIFICANT MINERAL
DEPOSITS HAVE THE PROMISE OF
MEETING SOME OF THE WORLD'S
GROWING DEMAND F